some of the embossing wheels at this
shop date back to 1908 the oldest wheels
are made of bronze and the newer ones
are made of steel there are hundreds of
patterns to choose from the worker
selects the wheel with the desired
pattern he mounts it to an embossing
machine that was built in 1908 the
worker locks the embossing wheel onto
the shaft he ignites torches that heat
the embossing wheel as the hot wheel
revolves it presses the pattern into the
molded strip of wood the heat releases
moisture from the wood preventing
splintering during embossing a drive
wheel below works in concert with the
embossing wheel to move the wood forward
next up are rosettes that are used to
accentuate the corners of furniture
windows and doors
using a sliding apparatus known as a
sled the woodworker delivers a board to
the teeth of a saw
he makes straight cuts and squares to
the desired dimensions the worker draws
lines from one corner of the wood square
to another and from the opposite sides
the lines intersect at the exact center
of the square the worker clamps the
square in a milling machine with the
cutting tool aimed directly at the
center he activates the tool to make the
first circular cut he removes the wood
square to check out the cut
the worker measures it to confirm that
it is in fact dead center he returns the
square to the platform under the milling
tool this time the cutter spins into the
wood to make a wider and deeper circular
cut this further expands the pattern in
a radial fashion
and it completes the rosette pattern
the worker examines the quality of the
cut and measures the distance to the
edge of the wood to verify that it's too
speck from a simple wood square to an
elegant rosette this job is done the
trim can now be used to make furniture
look hand-carved without all the effort